شكل عام 2003 نقطه تحول في اقتحامات
المستوطنين اليهود للمسجد الاقصى المبارك
انذاك سمحت شرطه الاحتلال للمستوطنين
باقتحامه تحت حمايتها كامر واقع التقسيم
الزمني الذي تحاول اسرائيل فرضه يعني
تخصيص اوقات محدده لدخول المسلمين واخرى
خاصه باليهود باقتسام الساعات والايام
طوال
العام بموجبه بات على المسلمين افراغ
المسجد الاقصى لساعات محدده يوميا ليصلي
اليهود ثلاث صلوات في الاقصى وتسعى
اسرائيل الى تخصيص المسجد الاقصى لليهود
خلال اعيادهم التي تصل الى 100 يوم وجميع
ايام
السبت والتقسيم المكاني هو تخصيص مناطق
وزوايا معينه من المسجد الاقصى لكل من
الطرفين حيث تسعى الحكومه الاسرائيليه
لاقتطاع
منطقتين ينظر الى محاولات اسرائيل لفرض
التقسيم الزمني والمكاني
[موسيقى]
كخرقة
ولتنفيذ مخططاتها تعتمد اسرائيل على قانون
القوه تعمد لابعاد المصلين لاشهر تمنع من
هم دون الاربعين من الصلاه في الاقصى تحضر
ما تسميه تنظيم المرابطين
والمرابطات وتعتدي على المعتكفين
[موسيقى]